buongiorno vavi lanterna dove siamo
[Risate]
sono molto avvio ha già iniziato blog ma
è proprio il mio ruolo
ora che la più forte alla regia questo
scottante di qua siamo a loreto a milano
e caiazzo diretta il posto dove stiamo
andando a cannes che ti sembra secondo
la tibia una città in provincia di
messina regola dei terzi stati c'è la
griglia di me moltissimo stanno
arrivando nei commenti molto carini c'è
stato un commento comunque fatto
piangere che ti dirò perché non sapeva
professore che ha scritto oggi funge da
milano però feste balli zarina
[Applauso]
intese io lo posso fare potrei fare
[Musica]
siamo a milano a dicembre c'è il sole e
vedete se molto sentito diranno fadoi
sia una cosa positiva scusate sembrò del
suo fa un freddo cane c'è sony ma sempre
freddo e mi stavo vedendo ricordato da
piccioni le persone vince gente che
scappa da vicino la motivo in realtà per
cui siamo venuti qua è legato al fatto
che in meno di 24 ore sarà il compleanno
di graziana chi ancora non lo ha fatto
un regalo ci ho pensato ma non ho
trovato niente e quindi adesso faremo
una cosa che ora non vede più le mie
stories buongiorno ragazzi
è un po bloccato grazie a tante storie
che vorrei fare le ho pagate al sicuro
che sfruttano meglio
a chiedere
tra i regali
c'e poi una cosa che ti faccia bene dove
sto rispetto il crollo
la ricetta il regalo perfetto ma prima
io vorrei andare alla ricerca di un
attenzione
vediamo di fare un salto starbucks
vai andiamo andiamo
da qui un albero di natale a natale non
è mai aspettato la vista per farti
notare una cosa gravissima
princi
niente strade calabresi ed è qui che
subentra un pochino di voiceover scusate
sono a letto quindi s'è sentito una voce
strane anche per quello comunque questo
è starbucks è il motivo per cui ve lo
sto raccontando così è sia per rendere
l'informazione più chiara e sia perché
non so se non siete resi conto ma
l'audio un po strano comunque abbiamo
fatto un giro finché a un certo punto
nel successo una cosa stranissima e ha
appena incontrato una ragazza
gentilissima che ci sta facendo la
cicerone per tutto il posto ma non
sappiamo se possiamo riprenderla in
quanto lavora qui e quindi di di di un
chan ha da fuori che state vedendo non è
un video sponsorizzato in realtà con
l'estate vedendo sono tutti quanti vari
metodi di estrazione perché ci hanno
spiegato che questo bancone che vedete
qua a sette diversi modi per estrarre
diverse miscele di caffè me ne ricordo
veramente pochi ma sono tendenzialmente
quelli che vi sto mostrando invidio
questa invece la tosta tritsch e che
preleva automaticamente il caffè dato
stare e poi lo mette interno di questo
casco nel quale riposerà per sette
giorni al fine di eliminare tutto quanto
il gas che si crea durante la tostatura
poi il caffè viaggia attraverso questi
tubi che vedete qui e raggiunge scusate
la mano tremolante il bar la sotto
quest'ultima qualcuno flight tracciatore
trim cold light of io la fine sono
rimasti abbastanza sconvolti dalla
gentilezza di questa ragazza che ci ha
subito offerto queste tre bevande da
degustare tutte estratte a freddo
calcolate che quella che sta prendendo
la vigna adesso passa addirittura
attraverso l'azoto liquido io in realtà
mi sono buttato subito a saggiarne
un'altra al cioccolato che per certi
versi può ricordare il frappuccino con
l'unica differenza che questo è
veramente si sente in bocca che è
pazzesco
per non è riscaldato
[Musica]
non è una sponsorizzazione giuro sul mio
onore e lo giuro
a dirlo in ritmo charlie dentro da
popoli per 18 navale
lo prendo questo ragazzo ci ha fatto poi
salire sopra in mezzo almeno dal quale
si vede i locali in maniera meravigliosa
e lì siamo stati serviti da carlo che ci
ha fatto vivere un'esperienza con quest
anno se vedete qui che è una kennex per
ora prima di fare la creme voglio
condividere con voi una cosa che è una
delle mie preferite io vari i lussi nel
mio lavoro
il suo numero uno però è sentire il
cappello ma senato 10 secondi fa per far
dilagare
c'è un profumo e irripetibile la
kermesse la conoscevo già per via di prè
talks che è un programma e sto facendo
con tra in video che invito a guardare e
ovviamente non avevo la minima idea che
per prepararla bisognasse fare tutte
queste cose vedete delle spirali con
l'acqua che scende pian piano
bisogna lasciarla poi riposare ea un
certo punto di prendere queste quella
schiuma in ha masticato del quale
dell'espresso che la parte più amara per
gli oli essenziali del chicco di caffè
lo mescola perché avendo fatto due pause
all'interno e traversi estratto tre
caffè differenti
adesso diventa un caffè morricone sembra
un set o un amaro o una salsa di soia
prima fase smelling quindi annotiamo il
caffè se non avete profumi lozioni
profumate e mettendo anche la mano a
coppa sopra il vostro contenitore
allora io ci sento sicuramente un odore
un po dolce gli odori dolci però non
esistono esistono i sapori dolci
quindi poi assaggiando un andremo a
ricercarlo il secondo e cioccolato
fondente che parteciperà muses il signor
genta strategicamente eretica aspira su
nebulizzate la classica quella che si fa
assaggiando il vino l'olio faccio vedere
come si fa io personalmente respiro
tutta l'area che ho e poi come in questo
modo
bagnatica la bocca che la lingua con il
caffè cioè non è non è capito non è
caffè non so se capitolo sun correndo
aspirazioni
la vide assaggiarlo perché no no
aspirarlo turbarlo è buonissimo
una delle cose che mi ha colpito di più
è stata quella di scoprire che esistono
molti più retrogusti tra virgolette di
caffè che vedete anche qua nel suo
processo di maturazione rispetto al vino
al vino
e io ho sempre prestato nel caffè fosse
fondamentalmente uno a questo punto ci
hanno aperto il casco che vedete qui
davanti per farci vedere anche che chi
ha creato questo posto ha pensato di
colorare la parte interna di queste ante
da rosso a viola che presidente del
processo di maturazione delle di queste
ciliegie che non sapevo fossero ciliegie
che contengono poi il caffè c'è inoltre
una parete con la realtà aumentata
sono rimasto a guardare a bocca aperta
il nostro secondo cicerone che mi faceva
vedere come inquadrando la parete tu
potessi avete vari gusti
oppure in un'altra schermata ci sono
varie mete in un'altra parete numero
manco reso conto che ci fosse il duomo
di milano ho fatto tutto quanto con le
bustine di caffè né che il pavimento che
ricorda moltissimo la tradizione di
milano per colori materiali forme allo
stesso tempo avesse una controparte il
soffitto che però vuole rappresentare in
chiave più moderna sia la palette di
colori che è un irregolarità che diventa
però più geometriche [ __ ] e infine
c'è lui il bagno questi specchio
rubinetti e quelli nurmi lavandino sono
un'opera d'arte
siamo appena usciti da starbucks tengono
abbiamo passato dentro bellissimo due
ore che ho fatto di due ore in realtà
nella quale abbiamo bevuto qualsiasi
cosa siano calcolati che noi abbiamo
parlato niente del regalo di graziare al
complimento
ho mai potuto ricevere sei mai male
dimentica
allora nella nostra location dove veniva
di qualcuno città del mondo al mondo
tramite quelle psiche
nessuno ci farà del male il team di
consegne rete tutti
no
il mezzo è sottovalutato
assolutamente sottovalutato ma voi
conoscete qualcosa di più stupefacente a
360 gradi di quei tre teste quello che
mangiamo un file ufficio quello che
volevo dire è che continuiamo a non aver
fatto il regalo a graziano il regalo di
graziare ma devo trovare il modo perché
devo leggere i commenti consigli una
smartbox mela smartphone come quando non
conosci che davanti sopra la smart box
c'è poco scritto non so che regalo farti
il foehn dyson che non so quanto costi
però di una stella sono sì ma 7 mega di
una stella o incazzo profumo troppo
personale uno grosso e nero cosa troverò
una cosa da rivelarle e che è bellissima
questa sera amo totalmente le darò tipo
una cosa arrivando e la classica regalo
sta arrivando
me l'ha fatto pure lei che stava
arrivando il mio regalo quindi non mi
sentirei in colpa adesso non mi sono
svegliato all'ultimo sono arrivato a
casa e mi è venuta finalmente l'idea so
perché ma tutele mi vengono il più delle
volte quando sto in bagno però
fondamentalmente credo che il regalo
migliore da fra graziana e mentalmente
più comodo così
dicevo il regalo migliore da fra
graziana crearle un gioiello con
un'incisione o con un disegno fatto da
me io torno in un modo e un qualcosa
quindi ora prenderò lui ipad
lei apple penn e mi metterò al lavoro
allora questo blog rete adesso ho fatto
questo occhio con questo simbolo
dell'infinito una sorta di visione di
cose che vanno oltre le cose avanguardia
pura che cosa all'occhio sexy
no non è bello un giorno ebbe dai ma
deve essere semplice non deve essere
chissà che cosa
un braccio le date disegnato per tante
persone invece sto disegnando magari una
cosa banale ma solo per lei
ciao in bocca al lupo lo zucchero ci
sono quei simboli che ne sono molto
carini non tutto è spiegabile ma è anche
bello così se non è di quelle cose che
si possono analizzare e scoprire col
tempo determinato in maniera e con la
specie umana satan eccolo ok adesso l'ho
passato da qui a qui
queste le prime 3 di sony sembra una
cosa da gli immigrati cioè ostica se ok
lo ha appena detto che fa cagare come
viene sarebbe stato meglio se fosse
stato tipo un layout bello capito che tu
vedi solamente il disegnino ammesso tipo
medaglietta del cane dice che fa cagare
troverò un altro regalo sono pezzi e
credo che questa giornata debba finire
un certo punto ok
and the winner is gucci e the winner is
this orecchino gucci grazie mille amica
è andata così
ne sa essere più contento di quello
proprio